-Anthony,
welcome back to the show.
It's always great
to see you, bud.
You look great.
-Thank you.
Always -- Always a pleasure
being here with you, Jimmy.
-You're in New York,
and I heard that you got to do
a little golf,
which I'm excited about.
-I did.
-'Cause I -- you're a good --
you're a great golfer.
-I'm a decent golfer.
-And you're fun to play with.
-That I am.
-Yes.
And how did you do?
-We took third place.
-That's not bad.
-Yeah, I played in CC --
CC Sabathia's golf tournament
this past Monday.
-Oh, I love what he does.
-Yeah, up at
Alpine Country Club.
It rained on us.
Poured on us.
-Did it really?
-So we only got to finish
14 holes, but we were 9 under.
And we thought,
"9 under could actually win it."
Well, we found out 9 under took
third place, which isn't bad.
So the awards ceremony,
at the end of the day,
in the rain, under a tent, they
announced seventh-place winner,
sixth-place winner,
fifth-place winner,
fourth-place winner,
but when they --
before they got that --
they got to Worst Golfer.
Worst Golfer
went to my boy, Ebro,
who's a radio personality here.
-Yeah.
-Worst Golfer
got an all-expense trip --
all-expense-paid trip
to the Bahamas.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. Worst Golfer?
-Where the hell do you give the
worst golfer a free trip...
[ Laughter ]
...to the Bahamas,
to stay at Baha Mar?
-What?!
-Where do you do that at?!
-And $500 spa credits a day
for a four-day trip!
-Wait. What?
-Worst Golfer should get
golf lessons!
Am I correct?!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wait. What?
-They gave Ebro
a four-day vacation to the
Bahamas and $500 credit a day.
-What did third place get?
-An umbrella.
-Oh, this is insane.
-Seventh place got an umbrella,
sixth place got an umbrella.
fifth place got an umbrella,
fourth place got an umbrella...
-In the rain.
-...third place got an umbrella,
second place got an umbrella,
first place got an umbrella!
[ Laughter ]
-And it rained that day.
You could've used
the umbrella earlier.
-Could've used the day.
I-I don't know if they got
a deal on the umbrellas
that day.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "We're just gonna
give this to everybody,
but what we really gonna give
is the worst golfer
a trip to the Bahamas."
-The Bahamas. Gosh.
Can he bring us?
-I hope so.
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
-I'm tagging along.
-How's --
Dude, remember last time?
We were talking about you
going back to school
and finishing your degree.
-Yes.
-And you went to --
is it Howard?
-Howard University.
-That's right.
-Yes, sir.
-How's that going?
Are you still doing that?
[ Applause ]
-Thank you.
It's -- It's going well.
I got a call
about a month or so ago
that I had fulfilled
my requirements.
-No way.
-Yeah.
-Hey, bud. Yeah!
-Thank you.
-That's what I'm talking about,
buddy.
-I have fulfilled
my requirements.
I think I have one class
to take in the spring,
but I will be walking, spring
2022, to get my degree.
I started --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-That's the best, buddy.
-I started Howard University
as a freshman, 1988.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that right?
-Yeah, 1988.
Getting my degree from Howard,
2022.
-Yeah, that's the best.
[ Laughter ]
-You do the math.
-You do the --
I don't know, carry the one.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
-If you do the math,
you add this over here.
I don't know.
It's a lot.
-I love that you did it, though.
You know, you're like,
"Yeah, I'm gonna do it."
-Yeah.
-And then you did it.
-Yeah, 30 --
I think 34 years, yeah.
Yeah, some people never go back,
but, you know, my children
inspired me once they
went to college, and I was like,
"Yo, I'm gonna go back
and get my degree."
-I want to say congrats, also,
on "Black-ish."
This is the final season.
-Yeah.
-And you've been nominated
11 times and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Uh, ask me
how many times I've won.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you get an umbrella?
-I'm the black Susan Lucci.
-Did you --
[ Laughter ]
Susan Lucci, I love it.
-I'll tell you why --
I'll tell you why --
that you're so good
and you get nominated
for the Emmys.
Because you do something
that no one else does.
You're funny.
You're so funny in this show,
but then, you can also turn it
and make it emotional
in, like, the drop of a hat.
-Thank you.
-And it's amazing,
the talent you have, and I --
Honestly, there's no one
out there doing that like you.
You're fantastic.
-Oh, thank you, Jimmy.
I appreciate that.
-I mean it.
-Thank you, brother, yeah.
-No one else -- it's amazing.
But the final --
the final season, this is --
-Yeah.
-It's emotional, huh?
-It's emotional.
It's bittersweet right now.
We're a little more than
halfway done with the season.
Now sadness is starting
to creep in,
because every day we go to work,
it's one day closer
to bringing that -- that chapter
of all of our lives to an end.
So, yeah, it's getting sad now.
-You've done such great work,
and there's, like,
important shows, as well.
-Yeah.
-Any hints on the final show,
or you can't give it away?
-I can't tell you that,
but it is presidential.
I'll just leave it at that.
-Wow. That's a good --
-Yeah.
That's a good hint.
-Yeah, I'll leave it at that.
Has nothing to do
with this president, though,
but it's presidential.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But it's interesting.
Sometimes people come on, I go,
"Can you give us a hint?"
and they go,
"Yeah, I can't say anything."
-No.
-You just gave us
a little something.
-I'll give you
-Thank you.
I appreciate that.
-Yeah, don't know if it's
true or not, but okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I got to finally --
Oh, I met -- but I got to see
your mom backstage...
-Yeah.
-...Doris, who I love...
-...who I think is, you know,
Well...
-She's a star in her own right.
-She is the star.
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
She is unbelievable.
-Jimmy -- Jimmy, don't --
Don't contribute to that.
You're throwing gasoline
on the monster fire
that I've created with my mom.
-That you created with your mom.
But your mom is un--
-She's a monster.
-Doris, is -- is this
Doris is here, right?
-Mom, where are you?
-Is she in the -- that's Doris.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at this.
That's what I'm talking about.
Gorgeous.
And next to --
next to your mom...
-Next to my mom is my son.
Take your mask off, son.
Let the world
see your pretty face.
Son, they're putting
cameras on you, son.
Say what's up.
-I'm all right.
I'm whatever.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, all right.
-My grandbaby.
-Yeah.
-That's right.
Doris, I have to say --
Oh, obviously, you're proud of
your son, but, man, oh, man,
we have discovered
something amazing in you.
I know --
-Me too.
[ Laughter ]
-"Me too."
-[ Laughing ]
-Doris, I heard that you have
a new -- a new boyfriend.
Is that true?
-Yeah.
-Yeah?
How's that going?
[ Laughter ]
-His name is Irving Theal.
He's a pilot.
-Oh, really?
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-33 years at American Airlines.
-Hey!
[ Laughter ]
That's not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It don't work!
It don't work!
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, Irving!
It don't work!
[ Laughter ]
That's what my mama say!
-Don't say -- now, that's --
-My mama say it don't work!
-That was between us!
That was between --
[ Cymbal crash ]
[ Laughter ]
Now I wanna --
-Came to me, talking about,
"You gonna call me daddy."
No, I ain't!
[ Laughter ]
I'mma tell the world --
"It don't work!"
-Oh, my God.
Everything's adjustable.
[ Laughter ]
We'll talk about it.
I want to talk about the new --
your new show.
It's a prank show called
"House Haunters."
-Yes.
-It's on Discovery+,
and I think it's a great idea.
How did the idea come about
to work with your mom on this?
-You know,
Discovery+ came to me,
said, "We got this idea."
We want to do our version
of a prank show,
"House Haunters,"
and we want you
and your mother to do it."
I said, "Let me call my mom,
see if she's available."
Before I could get a --
she said, "Yeah, where we going?
When we doing it?
When we going?"
[ Laughter ]
I said --
I said, "Okay, Mommy,
you don't have to worry.
You're not worried about
getting paid or anything?"
"Yeah, you gonna
take care of me.
You gonna make sure I get paid.
When do we go?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-So we shot it here in New York
earlier this summer.
Six fantastic homes that they --
they rigged with cameras
and booby-trapped
with a lot of excitement
and just invited prospective
buyers, interior decorators,
Realtors in who had no idea
what was going on.
And we surprised them
with pranks with snakes --
14-, 15-foot-long pythons.
It was --
It was amazing.
-Speaking of that,
it don't work.
[ Laughter ]
All right, sorry.
But you know what I like
about Discovery+,
I think what they do is they --
they make, like,
appointment television.
-Yes.
-Like, I mean, you --
So it's perfect for now.
It's October.
People want to get scared.
I want to show everyone.
It's very funny.
Here's Anthony Anderson
and his beautiful mom, Doris,
in "House Haunters."
Take a look.
-Bring in the girl.
[ Laughter ]
-Come here.
-No!
[ Screaming ]
-[ Laughing ]
-And what the hell?
Oh.
It's crazy.
It's creepy.
♪♪
-[ Screaming ]
[ Both laugh ]
-I watch you sleep.
[ Laughs ]
-What do we do?
-Uh, just fight it, I guess?
-Let's go, mama.
Let's go, let's go.
Let's go.
-"Fight it, I guess"?
What is he talking about?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sometimes they didn't work.
-It's that laugh
that is the best.
-Sometimes it didn't work.
-Anthony Anderson, everybody.
"House Haunters" premieres
tomorrow on Discovery+.